on va parler de vous
Eric Coquerel ça fait bientôt un an que
vous pilotez cette commission des
finances vous êtes imposé à entendre
beaucoup de vos collègues même si la
crise des retraites a élargi le nombre
de vos ennemies on l'a entendu il y a un
instant et bien regardez c'est dans
l'invitation Marion Becker petit
portrait et on discute juste après
[Musique]
si on vous invite
Eric Coquerel c'est parce que vous êtes
l'un des personnages clés du dernier
feuilleton de l'Assemblée sur les
retraites en tant que président de la
commission des finances tous les
projecteurs étaient braqués sur vous
avec cette interrogation
alliez-vous déclaré y recevable la
proposition de loi d'abrogation de cette
réforme des retraites et bien non non
malgré les pressions ironie du sort vous
défendez la proposition d'un homme qui
n'a pas approuvé votre nomination il y a
un an Charles de Courson s'y serait bien
vu et lui comme d'autres doutait de vos
compétences depuis vous avez su
convaincre à ce poste crucial
d'ordinaire confié à une personnalité
modérée vous êtes même reconnu par vos
opposants c'est bien mis dans son habit
de Président il est courtois respectueux
je dirais à la fois de manière
collective vis-à-vis des groupes
politiques et également de manière
individuelle assez attentionnée
finalement aux députés aux membres de la
commission des finances comme président
de la commission
drôle de destin pour un homme qui a été
annar à l'adolescence puis trop de kyste
pendant vos années étudiantes pendant 15
ans à la Ligue et communiste
révolutionnaire avant votre rencontre
avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon en 2008
député depuis 2017 vos engagements
restent intacts modérés sur la forme
mais radicale intransigeant sur le fond
et défenseur des classes populaires des
quartiers l'un des premiers de votre
partie à lutter contre l'islamophobie
aujourd'hui vous voilà sur un siège
éjectable le fait d'avoir validé la
proposition de loi d'abrogation de la
réforme des retraites a provoqué le
cours ou de la majorité
et ce qui va bien c'est que là il a
piétiné sa fonction en faisant cela j'ai
rien contre le l'homme en particulier
c'est simplement voilà il fait passer
ses convictions politiques avant
l'intérêt général de l'institution et ça
je ne m'accepte pas vous pourriez ne pas
être renouvelé à la tête de la
commission des finances en octobre alors
on a une question pour vous Éric
Coquerel vous sentez vous vraiment
menacé
réponse certains menaces en tout cas
mais j'ai remarqué pour l'instant en
tout cas j'ai eu le plaisir de voir
qu'aucun commissaire de des finances
quels qu'ils soient à un professé ce
genre de menace
c'est vrai qu'en général les
reconditions sont assises tous les
postes clés à l'Assemblée vont être
renouvelés c'est le cas chaque année
cette fois-ci pour y avoir un vote une
première vous me direz cette majorité
fait beaucoup de premiers
inédite mais ça voudrait dire plusieurs
choses ça voudrait dire déjà que il
faudrait trouver notre opposition qui
est envie de jouer un rôle de
perdez moi l'expression de de position
croupion c'est à dire être l'opposition
qui va bien à la majorité c'est pas ça
que ça sert un président de la
commission des finances pour et puis il
faudrait aussi que la majorité vote ce
qui n'a jamais été fait parce que si
c'est pas le cas il y aura la même vote
que la dernière fois ce qu'ils veulent
un vote et je serai de nouveau élu j'ai
même l'impression à écouter certains que
il y a une reconnaissance un peu plus
générale absolument mon rôle
je pense que vous n'auriez trouvé aucune
critique donc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
c'est que simplement je n'ai pas voulu
accepter les déshyratta de la majorité
sur quelque chose que j'estimais injuste
c'est-à-dire de déclarer y recevable une
proposition de loi dont la jurisprudence
faisait qu'elle devait l'être elle
devait être recevable et on a bien
compris que vous l'assumez vous ne le
regrettez pas mais donc il faut ça ça
renvoie quelque chose je pense que je
parle très souvent je pense que la
majorité est arrivée à un moment un
moment où il faut qu'elle accepte des
oppositions voilà il faut qu'elle
accepte que des gens ne soient pas
d'accord avec elle et donc en
l'occurrence un président de la
commission des finances c'est le seul il
y a pas d'autres présidents qui soient
l'opposition parce que c'est un
contre-pouvoir ce qui a d'ailleurs voulu
que vous êtes sceptique sur le fait même
d'intégrer qu'elle n'a pas la majorité
absolue
de le faire à vos yeux on verra bien moi
ce que je sais c'est que tout le monde
n'entonne pas le même discours j'ai
entendu quand même
dans la macronie tout le monde ne dit
pas la même chose donc j'espère que il
va pas y avoir d'autres lignes rouges de
franchis mais je vous dis encore
faudrait-il trouver une opposition qui
accepte de jouer ce rôle là et je ne
suis pas du tout sûr de ce résultat donc
je regarde ça on verra bien je veux pas
vivre la règlement de l'Assemblée elle
revient cette présidence de commission à
l'opposition et ça ça ne va
pas changer pour vous ça a changé quoi
d'être présidente commission c'est une
commission absolument stratégique elle
est très puissante vous regardez les
budgets mais pas seulement
c'est plus compliqué qu'être dans
l'opposition clairement
ça me permet c'est une commission qui
est intéressante qu'on touche à tout en
fait et on touche absolument à tous les
sujets puisque tout est financier donc
du coup on peut développer déjà des
connaissances des pratiques une
connaissance
aussi de de ce qu'il faut faire en
termes financier économique et autres
bon j'avais déjà un bon bagage quand
même parce que je suis un militant
politique depuis très longtemps donc
militants politiques vous intéressez à
l'économie mais c'est clair que ça m'a
ça m'a permis de m'enrichir tu sais bien
non mais en plus je suis naturel comme
ça c'est moi je viens du rugby etc
j'aime bien j'aime bien le collectif et
c'est vrai que c'est aussi un plaisir
d'essayer de à la fois
mettre ma marque alors ma marque ça
passe par exemple par rapport à des gens
que jauditionne
qui sont un moment qui vous a marqué
dans ces un an de commission s'il devait
y en avoir un j'en ai plusieurs j'ai
fait en sorte une mission spéciale c'est
chaque il y a des missions par qui sont
définies par budget et qui sont donnés à
des rapports spéciaux et j'en ai proposé
une pour Charles Leduc sur l'évasion
fiscale bon ça c'est quelque chose qui
est un peu ma pâte c'est à dire que non
il y a quelqu'un qui tous les ans
travaillent là-dessus et puis c'est
aussi la le fait de donner par un pas
des commissaires spéciaux le soin
d'avoir des cartes des cartes blanches
ils invitent qui veulent pour parler de
sujets alors c'est des sujets très
différents ça peut venir les bailleurs
sociaux d'autres c'était sur l'économie
de montagne etc et puis enfin là par
exemple on va auditionner Pisany ferries
dans peu de temps la présidente de
France Télévision il y a des problèmes
de budget donc j'essaye de diversifier
diversifier les gens que nous
auditionnons voilà c'est aussi et puis
il y a aussi les autoroutes où je me
suis un peu je me suis un peu débrouillé
pour que le dossier révélé par les
cadres enchaînés monte un peu en
puissance sur la façon dont les les
concessionnaires d'autoroute avaient
largement profité de la privatisation et
j'ai vu que ça avançait donc vous voyez
c'est aussi ce genre de dossier donc
vous pesez il y a un impact on le sent à
regarder de près les budgets les
réformes de ce gouvernement est-ce que
vous rejetez tout en bloc de la
politique économique d'Emmanuel Macron
les chiffres de l'emploi sont tombés ce
matin et ils sont encore bons Céline c
plus 0,3% c'est le 9e trimestre en
hausse c'est pas rien d'avoir fait
vraiment baisser le chômage non oui
alors il faut regarder un peu plus
précisément c'est pas pour vous l'aviez
mais je vois aussi que on est dans la
sixième puissance économique au monde et
on a un record de pauvreté comme on n'a
jamais eu
j'observe aussi ce que disent les
statisticiens sur le chômage par exemple
aujourd'hui malheureusement ceux qui
sortent du chômage c'est plus des gens
qui se désinscrivent et qui ne sont plus
sur le marché de l'emploi plutôt que des
gens qui cherchent un emploi c'est aussi
le fait que par exemple depuis
maintenant un an on a changé les
statistiques on compte les gens qui sont
en apprentissage et vous savez que
l'apprentissage est une politique
massive qui a voulu ce gouvernement à
mon avis au détriment des lycées
professionnels mais c'est une autre
question
des emplois créés le sont directement au
CDI ça ça change l'emploi industriel
aussi repart
industriel
niveau de 2015 je dis ça parce que on a
on a comme ça des des annonces de
chiffres qui ne correspondent pas à la
situation économique du pays d'accord ce
qu'il y a aussi c'est un pouvoir d'achat
en berne et des salaires qui ne suivent
pas l'inflation ce qui fait que les gens
de plus en plus de mal ce qui a aussi
c'est une crise de logement absolument
centrée d'exploser une crise de nos
services publics
notre économie elle crée 250 à 260 000
emplois par an des emplois ça peut être
quelques heures par semaine d'après
l'Insee donc je trouve que le bilan
d'abord il est pas meilleur que d'autres
pays européens et il est pas aussi
mérifique que le gouvernement et je
crains d'après ce que dit aussi l'Insee
que les que l'avenir soit moins rose que
ne le prétend le gouvernement Emmanuel
Macron parlons un peu de la France
insoumise votre mouvement vous le fidèle
d'entre les filets de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
vous faites partie de ces insoumis qui
ont été écartées de la coordination du
mouvement vous l'avez bien vécu ça bon
je dis ce que j'avais à dire à ce moment
là et puis c'est derrière vous oui oui
parce que je me concentre sur des
questions qui me semblent plus important
je dis pas que les questions de de
d'organisation démocratie ne sont pas ça
m'intéresse mais moi j'ai toujours fait
le choix de de travailler
à l'Assemblée il intervient ça c'est pas
rien je finis juste c'est vrai que par
exemple si on regarde aujourd'hui je
préfère concentrer mon temps sur la
question de la me poser la réforme des
retraites etc que à la vie interne de
France insoumise c'est pas que mon
préoccupe pas c'est que je suis obligé
de hiérarchiser parce que j'ai qu'une
vie je comprends tout à fait et c'est là
que ça se passe aujourd'hui l'assemblée
est au cœur du pouvoir désormais mais il
intervient beaucoup dans cette vie
parlementaire sans siégé Jean-Luc
Mélenchon se souvient de son fameux
tweet sur l'article 7 la volonté de
continuer à vous faire entendre la
colère certains diront l'obstruction
franchement vous vivez bien ça ça vous
met pas de mal à l'aise
de stratégies au moment de l'article 7
bien évidemment on peut être d'accord ou
pas d'accord mais c'est normal on est un
mouvement avec 75 députés très
certainement le plus gros mouvement
politique de ce pays en termes de noms
d'adhérents donc fort heureusement vous
voudriez quoi qu'on soit tous alignés
dans notre groupe nous votons donc c'est
bien voilà qu'on n'est pas forcément le
même avis et puis après on fait des
bilans il y a une ligne qui a certains
moments l'emporte enfin souvent c'est
uniquement tactique c'est pas des
grandes questions stratégiques moi ça je
veux dire c'est l'inverse qui me
poserait problème bon et quand est
Jean-Luc moi je l'ai toujours dit je
continue à considérer Jean-Luc
aujourd'hui une autre leader voilà il y
a de français soumise même si il s'est
mis avec un pas de côté mais n'empêche
pour l'instant c'est lui qui d'un point
de vue stratégique programmatique et
tribunicien continue à nous représenter
le comportement possible en plus c'est
mon ami diriger tout ça fait que non ça
ne me dérange pas que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
interviennent ce qui ne m'empêche pas y
compris quand des fois je pars des
différences et bien de le défendre dans
les réunions de groupe et autres et
c'est pas pour ça qu'il m'en veut donc
il aura je ne sais plus exactement mais
75 ans en 2027 et donc est-ce que il est
temps de passer la main est-ce que vous
souhaitez qu'il soit candidat moi j'ai
dit que là aujourd'hui ici si les
élections potentiel arrivé maintenant
parce que lui-même met la question du
temps la question de
voilà de notre de notre finitude quelque
part dans la balance dans ce qu'il
pourra être fait aussi c'était
aujourd'hui je pense que ça serait le
notre meilleur candidat et pas François
Ruffin c'est pas la relève non je me dis
aujourd'hui je vous dis ça on verra bien
ce que dit voudra dire à Jean-Luc dans
dans les mois à venir quels sont ils le
dis même quels sont les circonstances et
puis après c'est parfait parce que
figurez-vous nous sommes plusieurs
Françoise
il fait des propositions moi je vous dis
une chose j'apprécie beaucoup François
on a des discussions des fois on n'est
pas toujours d'accord mais c'est parfait
je trouve que c'est bien qui quelqu'un
qui qui justement comme ça monte en
gamme il y en a d'autres on est
plusieurs à le faire je pense d'ailleurs
vous voyez vous me parlez je pense qu'on
est plusieurs à monter en gamme c'est
parfait et on verra bien toute la gauche
mais moi je vous dis 2027 c'est terminé
là dessus c'est que aujourd'hui là ce
qui me paraît le plus important pour
gagner en 2027
c'est le fait que la nupaise continue à
être ensemble sur un programme de
rupture parce que c'est ça elle ne pèse
pas seulement unité c'est sur un
programme de rupture
à l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui les élections
législatives et ça marche drôlement bien
l'assemblée vous nous avez vu faire un
serment aujourd'hui dire que nous
abrogerons la réforme cette réforme
économique tu nous reviendrons vers la
retraite à 60 ans donc nous disons des
choses ensemble moi j'ai bon espoir et
en tout cas je crois que c'est
nécessaire parce que c'est la condition
pour pouvoir remporter ses élections et
si on est ensemble on pourra l'emporter
et dans ces cas-là viendra le temps de
savoir qui
le thème
vieux classique merci c'est bien d'avoir
le programme avant fait on a fait une
journée en 2012 et en 2017 et en 202